- I am going to start with
our first question from Zoom,
which is around journals.
So I love this question
around scientific literature.
I'm open access advocate
for a decade or more.
So the question is, do you
think open source journals
should be more accessible to the public?
Why or why not?
And so I think maybe there are
two certain questions here.
There's this open source stuff like
bioRxiv, medRvix.
And the og arXiv, which is like the math
and physics source, pre print server.
And that's been around for a
really long time by the way.
So math and physics people
have had it going on
way longer than biologists.
So props to them.
But the peer reviewed stuff
is really inaccessible.
So I would love to hear
everybody here on our panel,
like where are you with that?
Do you think that this
should be open to the public?
- Hmm, so open to the public
as in, like accessible to read.
- (mumbles) I guess.
- I think that's the main thing.
Atleast that's how I understood it.
And I'm like Jeannie, a very
big advocate of open source
and I have been for a very long time.
But, I'm interested to see
what Emily and Lindsey think.
- Okay, for that, absolutely yes.
I wanted to clarify whether it was like,
accessible without a pay wall
or accessible in the
way that it's written.
Because I mean, I think
to like to some degree
that could also be made a bit better.
In terms of like the clarity with which
we write about research.
But definitely having the
research at least free,
like no price, free
accessible to the public,
should absolutely be
the case, in my opinion.
Yeah.
- Yeah I agree completely
with everything Em just said.
(laughing)
- That's great, yeah I mean I think
it makes complete sense.
A lot of this research is publicly funded
so it makes complete sense for the public
to actually have access to the results.
You know, the peer reviewed
results of this science.
Not just the archives but
actually open source publications
like PLOS and others would be, yeah.
It would be great.
- There is a couple of open
source journals like that,
elife, PLOS.
- Elife, yeah.
- And I will say that all
of the COVID-19 stuff,
is open to everybody on most journals,
I believe that this is open stuff.
- Nature and science for sure.
- Yeah.
- Great!
- Sorry did you...
(cross talking)
- Or maybe Pedro you can
take the next question.
- Okay, cool yeah that's
what I was going to do.
Sorry, I think I got a little
bit of audio interference.
But I think this is a
good question from Amanda,
and it goes into the
infectivity methodology
that you were talking about.
So what she wants to know if
these drugs were good on cells
already infected.
The drugs that did work on cells
that were already infected,
or on cells before they
were infected by the virus.
- Yeah so, in this paper
and in the figure that I've talked about.
They treated the cells with
the drug prior to infection.
So kinda like, prophylactically sort of.
And so they also in this
paper, we didn't talk about it,
they looked and they saw that
the drug was pretty good at
preventing infection for up,
if you gave it up to four hours
after you infected the cells.
So, what that really means
in terms of an organism,
like I really don't know maybe
someone else knows better.
But it's really hard to say
what four hours means in a cell,
in terms of a timeline and I think
that is a really important
follow up question.
Because obviously we need to
find drugs that can be used
to treat patients that
already have SARS-CoV-2.
And prophylactic is great, too.
- Great, so we have
this wonderful question
from Facebook from Aniesa.
You didn't not talk about this explicitly,
but if you caught it in the methods,
how do they know if they
prevented or reduced infections
with these drugs in the
cell culture experiment?
- Basically the way they did it was,
I think this might've been
part of the idea behind
designing it, where they gave
the drug before the virus.
Is they basically gave different
cells like plus minus drug,
of the same quantity
of virus and saw like,
in theory if the drug does nothing,
you should see the same
degree of infection
in both conditions.
But if the drug is preventing infection,
then you would see less infection
in the cells that received the drug.
If that answers the question.
But that is kinda how
the sought to measure.
(mumbles) infectivity.
- How do you look at infectivity?
Like how do they measure if something is
more infected or less infected.
Were you able to gather
that from the methods?
- I believe it was based
off of just the amount of
viral proteins or the amount
of viral RNA within the cell.
I believe that's what they did.
- Interesting, cool.
Thank you.
- All right so we've got
another question here
from Joann and they want to
know what type of cell lines
were used for these studies.
I think you mentioned at some point
if they were lung, cardiac, or gruel.
And they are referring to
specifically the amounts of
the ACE2 receptor which we already know
is involved in the virus
entering the cells.
That exists in cells from these
different types of tissue.
They mentioned human cell lines.
I remember you guys talked
about monkey cell lines
at some point but I don't know
if you want to go into that
with a little more detail.
- Um, sure.
So, for the original viral protein human
interaction experiments that
we saw at the very beginning.
Those took place in HEK 293T cell lines.
And those are kinda like
a work horse cell line
that we use with a lot
of stuff in cell biology.
Even kind of like piloting and testing
certain gene editing experiments.
A lot of times we do them in 293T's,
just because they are
super easy to work with.
Those are originally derived
from human kidney cells,
or human kidney I should say.
For the later experiments,
the infectivity experiments,
those were in I think they were VERO 6,
if I remember correctly.
- Yeah.
- Good.
- And those are monkey kidney cell lines.
And we use those, from what I read,
particularly in virology.
Because they are fairly easy to infect
and also monitor infection pretty easily.
So like, they kind of
design their cell lines
based on sort of like easily
designing their experiments
and then getting very clean
results they can control for.
- Great, and I think this
is a question that maybe
I could be the one to answer.
Because it's around, how
do students get involved in
biomedical research during this time
and as the director of RockEDU,
who runs biomedical research
programs for students,
I can tell you that I
don't know right now.
It's been a really tough time
for the research landscape.
I know a lot of summer
programs are being canceled.
I know for us our summer
science research program
is going virtual.
And so we are currently
dreaming up ways that
we can provide research experience
to our students and beyond.
So that they can go through the process
of science themselves.
And I just want to point out that,
in terms of the process of science what we
really wanna see people doing
is this iterative process.
You're gonna design something.
You're probably gonna have
some aspects of it that fail.
You're gonna figure out
how that failed, fix it up,
then redo it until you get
an answer that feel rigorous
and can be replicated by someone else
in an independent setting.
Right, and so that's the key to science.
It really needs to be something
that can be replicated.
And stay tuned for our D4P section.
We're hopefully going to
have a little but more stuff
coming soon in the corner
store science section,
that will allow people to engage with
the process of science.
And we're developing out
a couple of model systems
that you could do at home.
So stay tuned for that and hopefully
we'll have a better answer
for you in the coming weeks
for how to get involved.
- Great okay, then we'll
move on to the next question,
which is from Samantha.
And Samantha wants to know how long,
I think probably directed
actually at you two specifically.
How long have you been
following the trials.
I'm guessing how long
have you been looking at
clinical trials and using all of the tools
that you showed us YEM
that were super useful.
- Not that long.
So when I used to work in pharma,
I paid like a little bit
more attention to them
and that's where I got familiar
with the process generally.
Just from like being in that
world and in that field.
But kinda like I think as everyone has,
with all the news that's going on
and kinda the quick pace of like,
oh like this drug seems to be working,
now this drug seems to be working.
Now we're testing this drug.
I've definitely sort of
tuned back in to it again.
Just to try to keep tabs on
everything that's going on.
Even still, it's very hard.
(chuckling)
- I love your sort of reminder of
how all the different phases work.
I thought that was really really useful.
- Oh, glad to hear it, great.
(chuckling)
- So I'm going to ask
a question from Lauren.
And I love this question.
So considering that the
study found that SARS-CoV-2
interacted with 332
proteins, so just clarifying
that certain proteins within
the SARS coV-2 proteome
interacted with 332 human proteins.
So she asked if a drug
would be needed to prevent,
all of these, you know,
do you have to make a drug to prevent
all of these protein protein
interactions or just a few.
- Yeah, so I think we
would still need to like
figure that out for sure but I doubt
if that would be the case.
If anything, an example
that we could cite maybe,
tentatively from the study,
is that some of the drugs
that just targeted like
one or a few interactions
did reduce viral infectivity.
So it already suggests that
we don't need to go after
all of these proteins
which would be a doozy,
so that's good, to
actually see some effects.
I think sort of what's maybe more helpful
or maybe could be more
informative to us to
pay attention to here is kind of like,
what particular functions,
like we showed some of those
interaction maps that show proteins
that are all involved in the same job.
If certain drugs that go
after a certain function
are really effective at
preventing infectivity
or reducing infectivity,
then it might just be those functions
and then proteins
involved in that function.
That would be important for us to target.
Another caveat to this too,
is as Lindsey mentioned in the beginning,
the way that they sort
of did these experiments
is they expressed one
viral protein at a time
in these human cell
lines and that's not how
viral replication actually happens.
Because the virus gets in,
it replicates it's
entire self all at once.
So you have a lot of viral
proteins in a cell at a time.
So it's possible that
like in a condition where
you have this one viral
protein bopping around,
you might have interactions
happening there
that you wouldn't
necessarily see as opposed
to normal infection where you have all
the viral proteins in the cell at once.
So this is the kind of thing
that would have to be tested
sorta empirically, but my
guess would be probably not,
which is good.
- And I think it's worth
adding that most drugs
that are small molecules,
like the stuff that you,
the pills that you take, are
usually a small molecule.
A small molecule will typically
only have a single target,
right in just generally speaking.
So if they can disrupt
one of those targets,
they don't have to
disrupt everything else.
Because that's what
we're just looking for.
So I think that's a really,
it's really nice to think about
in terms of the science, so cool.
- Okay another question from Magnolia now.
And she stresses it's a
hypothetical question,
but I still think it's a good question
and good to go into about FDA approval.
So she asks if an existing drug was
found to help treat COVID-19
and was FDA approved again,
so for that purpose, what
effect could that have
on the people who already use that drug
to help treat other conditions?
Is there a way to produce
medications on larger scale
or are there restrictions?
- Yeah it's great.
Lindsey do you wanna take this one?
- Yeah, I guess I'll start.
My real answer is I don't know
what kind of an effect it would have.
I know it's been pretty,
like in addition too
the news talking a lot about how
chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine,
maybe might treat COVID-19.
There's also been a massive
shortage in those drugs
for people who actually need
them to treat other things,
like rheumatoid arthritis or lupus.
And that's a really big problem.
So I don't know the answer to,
if we find a drug that works
how do we mass produce it?
But I do think that's a super
important question to ask.
- That was my favorite niece Maggie.
So thank you so much for
your wonderful question.
(laughing)
Here's a question from Audrie.
I hope I'm pronouncing
your name correctly.
What evidence do they have
to determine if the drug has
effectively bound to
either that human protein
or to the viral protein to disrupt that
protein-protein interaction?
- Okay, so for human
proteins generally like,
so the sort of like the first
way that people will kinda
validate drugs to see if
they bind is basically
they'll look for a drug
that disrupts like,
if it's an enzyme,
like a certain reaction
the enzyme participates in.
Or like it will look for just
like the separate proteins
that are both involved in the interaction
and see like if the drug is there,
does this enzymatic reaction not happen?
And that would suggest
that the drug is like
preventing it from happening.
Or these two proteins that
we can usually isolate,
in the way that Lindsey
described while they're
stuck to each other, are they
no longer stuck to each other
when we give the drug?
So there are sorts of like,
that's kind of like the initial pass.
But another way that
people do it is actually,
and this I'm not super familiar with,
but I've just seen figures of it before.
We can do this technique
call x-ray crystallography
that actually lets us see like physically
the protein and the
compound bound together
and sort of verify that
those chemical interactions,
where the compound or the molecule,
I should say is kind of like basically
filling that binding
pocket in the protein,
like that actually lets us
see that it's truly happening.
But otherwise it's more
kind of like a functional
sort of like, does this
protein do different things
as you would expect it to if
the drug was binding to it.
- Okay so, I think this
question goes back to
what we talked about a
few minutes ago actually
about the giving the drug before or after
the cells were infected with the virus.
But I still let you expand.
Do you think that some of
these drugs at some point
will be used prophylactically
for the general public
who is not yet infected
to prevent infection.
- Maybe.
(laughing)
I think that depends a lot on their other,
what are their side effects they have?
So that's always something
that, keep in mind
with regards to the kind of like,
giving drugs for certain indications,
there's always a risk to benefit ratio
that you have to consider.
Especially if it's a prophylactic.
If that drugs comes with some
pretty harsh side effects
then you might not want to be taking it
just from the off chance that
you might get an infection.
But if you already have the
infection and it's really bad
and there's nothing else, then
you kind of are more willing
to kind of stomach the side effects
if it will help you get better.
So I think like that could come into play
in terms of those decisions.
But all of that stuff has
to be tested in trials.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.